[Musique]
vos papilles des passants je veux mais
brian currin a dit paresh de coups avant
mais ça m'embêtait drame
mais comme ans a demandé si je croise
les doigts
du jamais vu chez ses parents d'élèves
safari marc dumas n autorise pas
m
j'avais pris les traits pourquoi toi le
petit matin aujourd'hui c'est la journée
mondiale de la télé les chéris donc
chaque chroniqueur et dans la peau d'un
animateur ou d'une personne de
télévision je vais les faire entrer un
par un on va cueillir maintenant
vraiment une bonne on passait
d'intervilles
alors sachez que la tabasser une
personne n'est pas la giz et lé pas
déguisé donc voilà c'est ça va être
difficile de trouver mais n'est pas
déguiser isabelle
[Rires]
la mère foire c'est la plus aimable avec
maxime
bien entendu
attention on a le prochain ap fabien le
coeur fabien lecoeuvre
tu sers ça aux clients c'est de la merde
et les beaux jours du fc b je fais mais
il a été très bon chez toi un moment
j'ai pigé bay défonçage troicki très
bonne méthode comptable et a été très
bon fabien we were évite tout débute
aujourd'hui
l'aura du bar si on aura des polyvalents
comme moi vous n'avez tout ça et on
appelle chose on se retrouve dans un
instant les entrants
[Applaudissements]
siècle un nom
est ce que est ce que tu veux faire tout
de suite au début de l'émission tu fais
le bon choix
alors allez-vous mettre en place que
vous mettez deux heures bon les chéris
merci isabelle merci d'être là on ce
lundi était un hameau que nous nous
avait régalés à marrakech alors juste tu
vas de changer tu parles chez midas tout
de suite on était rejeté aujourd'hui on
reçoit quelqu'un que j'adore olivier
rousteing c'est un génie à l'îlot
exceptionnel c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
sa tenue de chérir y voit là est la
voilà la france soir on est on est on
est pas mal il se passe il ya une idée
là quelque chose il paraît qu'il a deux
surprises de ouf pour moi une qui a été
dévoyé par valérie benaïm est d'épargner
sait rien et une autre est une autre non
mais sérieux et mais je vous le dis
paraît qu'il a deux surprises de ouf
pour moi olivier il faut savoir que
c'est une star internationale des plus
grandes stars qu'on ait reçu dans cette
édition
je suis fan de lui en plus vous le dis
et son film est exceptionnellement vous
allez voir franchement les chaînes je
vous le dis restez avec nous parce que
vous allez kiffer voilà c'est un vrai
personnage il est exceptionnel voilà il
fallait me préfère je suis très content
qu'il soit là ça fait des semaines et
des semaines qu'on parle de sa venue les
chéris il ya eu une autre personne que
je kiffais c'est carla bien entendu car
là c'est l eurovision junior américaine
qu'est ce que j'ai fait dimanche à 16
heures j'ai tout arrêté à marrakech
aller faire du chameau aller faire des
trucs moi les mecs sur l'eurovision
junior on a terminé cinquième c'était le
mien c'est par elles pas sûr que j'ai
voté pour elle ça va coûter une blinde
home and away elle a fini cinquième
elle était troisième dans les votes du
public et ouais je vous lis les votes
pour la france ont doublé par rapport à
l'année dernière
bon les chevilles déjà bravo pourrir
c'est le deuxième meilleur score après
mon anniversaire
nous n'avons rien fait vous avez en
poche
si vous jouez je n'ai rien fait c'est
vous qui nous avez porté encore hier on
est dans une agitation bahamas à tomber
et là quand je vois ce cas là ça va
tomber également
il manque eric naulleau eric naulleau
hier qu est ce qu on lui avait dit on la
lui découvrir olivier aubin
[Applaudissements]
son bateau
aller en dessous
le jour sont faux
[Applaudissements]
j'en mets chauds et ses chants et bien
bien des fleurs des sceaux veut qu'avant
regardez non mais là c'est que les
regardez là on n'a pas le temps mais
normalement même mélange entre c'est un
truc qui me fait les meufs les matches
comme ça eric sur la tête de ma mère
q et non mais cette espèce me voir je
vais m'occuper de toi alors comme un
toilettage et cinq ans bien sûr comme
quoi les aménager ce prix là je viens de
regarder regarder ça la police est très
bon c'est ça que j'aime c'est sûr et
c'est ça qui lui va bien merci et bravo
en tout cas est al thani c'est un
parapluie dans ton slip
bon je suis très content encore ça
marche très fort et aujourd'hui on
retour de castaldi et deux de leurs maux
un petit peu sur la touche
voilà pour les reposer ils se sont
reposés ils sont bien regardé comme une
enfant et il a presque légendaire ce
petit cul regardez alors je voudrais
dire il vous a vu qu'un sondage il ya un
sondage qui est tombé quoi jeter a
baissé les yeux que tu me parles pas
baisser un petit bonne at on alors elle
m'a pas mis sur la touche de multi mis
sur la touche est ce que tu vas faire
attaquer maintenant c'est bon aloi nous
n'allons ni abri ah oui alors je vous
explique
[Musique]
bakou